the surgeon will perform a
colonic reception which is the removal of part
of your large intestine if you have
colorectal cancer or many other conditions the
colon is a long muscular tube located
at the end of the intestinal tract
after the stomach and
small intestine digest
Food Remaining material passes through the
colon where water and
electrolytes
are absorbed Residual stools pass into the last
6 inches of the colon known
as the rectum where they are stored
until evacuated Most
conditions that occur  treat with
colonic reception occur in the layer of cells
that cover the inner surface of the
colon known as the
mucosal lining colonic reception is normally
performed to treat colorectal cancer
one of the most common types of cancer
is also used to
treat others  conditions such as
intestinal obstruction
ulcerative colitis and crohn's disease
trauma to the post
intestinal  colon liposuction especially when there
are many and large
complications of diverticulitis
the ischemic intestine
before surgery a general anesthetic will be applied
so that you sleep
during the entire operation
a breathing tube will be inserted through the mouth and into the
trachea to help you breathe
the surgeon will begin  making an
incision in your abdomen over the part
of the colon that needs to be
removed the surgeon will clamp your colon with clamps in two places on either side of the section to be removed then cut the colon
where each clamp is located and remove
the diseased portion from the middle together  with
a healthy colon martin and surrounding tissue
finally the surgeon will sew up the
loose ends of the colon to join them together
after the procedure is finished the
surgeon will insert one or two drains
to remove fluid that may
accumulate around the
surgery site will close the wound  with stitches or
staples and cover it with bandages
after your procedure  you will be taken to
the recovery area for
close observation and antibiotics
and pain relief medications
will be given as needed you will be given fluids and
nutrients through an IV
then gradually transition from a
liquid to a solid diet over the
course of days  you will be encouraged to
get out of bed and move around as soon as
possible